hello freak [ __ ] okay that's a good
question who would you rather be around
the couple that's stabbing at each other
or the ideal couples is making you feel
like your relationship isn't so great
well the ideal couple for sure I want to
be around happy people yeah I want to be
around people that are enjoying each
other's company there's nothing more
frustrating than being around to people
that insult each other like slighly in
public full spirital we know a couple of
the Hartman's wife used to do that all
the time really yeah they say shouldn't
speak ill of the dead but when they kill
your friend and then kill themselves I
think you're a lot of talk show
absolutely there's no reverence in death
but but they had a very combative
relationship it's used to talk [ __ ]
about him in front of us really yeah
right in front of him and us it was just
like she was saying he's old and she
would you know she's like one time she's
talking about her car they were tough it
was talking about a car like you fills a
car aficionado well yes so we were
talking about a car I forget what it was
and then she goes I love pickup trucks I
want to get a pickup truck all my
boyfriend's back home that pickup trucks
and you just picture and her getting
stuffed in the back of his pickup truck
by some [ __ ] farmer boy some dude
thick wrists little catcher's mitt hands
and here just laying his fat dick they
let her take his pants off but saying
that like I don't know it's terrible
it's just weird and was it constantly
like that she was always belittling them
always tearing them down they would have
these horrible fights man I never
understand that it's like you're
together like it's for the good like his
success is your success and yet they'll
still tear them down well the people
don't think logically yeah I know what
you're saying but that's not a logical
thought yeah I mean that I think they
just didn't get along great you know
whatever reason phil was really [ __ ]
smart too he was the coolest he was a
really smart you're so lucky you got to
know him yeah he was um mark I mean he
would do things like he learned how to
be a pilot yeah so he would be on the
set and during the downtime he'd be
reading aviation books she is sitting
there reading going through him he was
the most studious guy Ken the most
disciplined with his notes he would have
his script and each one of his scenes
that he was in would have a certain
highlight
like like a tab like a green tab or
whatever the color tab was and then all
of the scenes would be highlighted he
have notes beside them Pacific parts of
the scene where he wanted to do
something different or so I questioned
his intent earlier yeah you know and and
he would just every time he would nail
it every time he was the incredibly rare
time where he would crack up during a
filming yeah you know I'm just having
fun yeah it's never like you [ __ ] up
but he never [ __ ] up right I mean
everybody [ __ ] up and laughs when
you're not supposed to laugh because
it's funny the time is games he was so
professional but he was a very very very
intelligent man oh he was a hard-on too
right yes any start out like designing I
design a home covers for bands yeah yeah
before he was ever even on SNL he was
also one of the greatest for pee-wee's
Playhouse right I mean II was on TV yeah
he was on pee-wee's Playhouse and I
think he wrote the first movie I think
he wrote pee-wee's big adventures one of
the writers really yeah what a great
that's amazing
so you got to hang with him a lot you
guys hang all the time he took me up in
his plane he did yeah it was crazy so is
to even buy a house and he was
suggesting on his different areas and
they said what do you like I said I just
like quiet I like peace oh I see things
that are pretty a nature and he's like
okay because I think it is an area like
right around like Thousand Oaks area
won't you check this out they take me up
in his plane
Wow flying around looking uh who's crazy
that I'm driving on the one I want to go
and he had like a small plane and great
freedom you have when you have a plane
you ever want to do that
fly yourself yeah but weird way to go
when you know this [ __ ] plane is
dying on you I've had cars die on me
yeah no I know the mechanical end of it
are you mechanical are you um not really
yeah I mean I know certain things but
it's like someone saying I took karate
when I was 14 right right I ran my own
stereo in my Toyota Corolla
I did that right I wouldn't tell you
that I can install stereo yeah yeah I
know a little bit about cars I love them
yeah I do too but that's the thing it's
like I feel like if you're gonna have
your own plane and you've got to be ya
know really knowledgeable and on top of
it and you got to know your limits and
that's kind of my limit
yeah it was intense man the landing was
intense a little tiny plane man was a
little two-seater plane so this me and
fell and we're coming into this landing
my Jesus is right there like a grounds
right crazy it's weird it was a small
plane and knowing that it's like your
goofy friend from the second yanking you
in well he was always um like an older
brother to me was on a set yeah he was
he was older than me Lito assyrians at
least 18 years older maybe more maybe
1718 years older so yeah and he was a
star already right yeah he was a star
yeah like when little gray we were on
the set he is in movies all the time you
know he was just getting off Saturn line
and you know and then of course Dave
Foley was a big star from kids in the
hall yeah he was a big alternative star
to like everybody loved him and because
he was so smart
yeah he was so good an Andy Dick was
like a known weirdo and so it was a
fascinating little great heroes yeah
great crew I remember spending a whole
summer just watching Phil's best of SNL
disc oh so fine and stuff that wasn't
even a hit like him playing the acting
teacher oh I mean I would watch it in a
loop I could not stop watching it
himself this is something this is
nothing this is something this is
nothing and then he was like Shh
somebody it's like sir can I get out of
my class it just it was I'm the money a
hundred percent of the time yeah man he
uh we always stand up to for the
audience for fun oh yeah he would like
warm up the crowd oh really you know he
was like putting together almost like a
little routine that he would do well and
we talked about his like I think I'm
gonna go on stage someday well he just
never I don't think you ever really did
it though but he could have easily done
it and his wife to God hey man she was
troubled you know who's a troubled
person and she was also on Zoloft and
cocaine oh my god which apparently leads
to psychotic thoughts and it's
apparently a very bad combination
especially for some people yeah people
have their own particular sort of human
neural chemistry they got going on up
there
and with some people they do coke and
zoloft together just makes them insane
yeah those are the real one of the real
losses as a fan of his is that he was
the kind of guy that the older he got
the better he would become yeah he was
playing guys who were older than him he
had that very fatherly intelligent older
kind of vibe anyway yeah so as a 75 80
year old he would still be killing it
yeah I think um I think there's a
million different kinds of tragedies
with the big one as those kids had to
deal with the fact killed them and then
killed themselves
committing to two hits and then they
went and lived with family afterwards
the whole thing's so dark it's so sad it
is man is the worst
[Applause]
[Music]